Now Joe, I'm going to talk
to you about your language.
Why the fuck do you swear so much?
I Dunno.
Have you read anything about
the science of swearing? No.
Do you know that there is a
science of swearing? Escience? Yes.
It's pretty interesting stuff.
Oh,
so the part of your brain that produces
swear words is not the part of the brain
that manages ordinary language.
Really interesting. Uh, you know,
we have two language centers
in our left frontal cortex. Uh,
people that have strokes that damage
them often lose language completely,
but they can still swear.
So swearing is coming from somewhere else.
It may be coming from
the right hemisphere,
but it's also coming from deeper centers
in the brain that connect to the limbic
system and the Amygdala. And that connects
to the involuntary nervous system.
So here's a couple of interesting facts.
Okay.
A swearing is associated with sweating,
increased sweating.
So you should be dripping with
sweat that much. I'm a comedian,
I'm sure. It's also
interesting swearing, uh,
increases pain tolerance. And there's
an interesting experiment. You know,
the standard way they do paint columns.
They have people stick their hand in a
bucket of ice and water and you see how
long they can keep it there.
That people who say fuck shit can keep
it there much longer than people who are
not allowed to swear. What about
noises? What if they just go, ah,
ah no, it was swearing specifically.
So they've tried noises and swearing.
So it may be, you know, when
you, uh, if you're hammering
a nail and hit your thumb,
you use one of those words.
That's a good strategy.
That's interesting because I almost
always do that. If I heard something,
especially a finger like a
slammed a car door the other day,
he said that's what that is. But that's,
yeah. And it's interesting. It's coming.
There's a different part of the brain
that manages that and it has different
emotional content. Yeah. It
flavors language. Yes. I live them.
I'm a big fan of the squares.
I'll leave you some papers
about the science of swearing.
It's interesting. Yeah.
It's very interesting now what it will,
what would happen if there were no
longer taboo with the same eight their,
I think they lose their power
because that, yeah, right.
The same areas of the brain wouldn't,
I remember there was an episode of,
I don't remember what television show,
but it was a on CBS. Yeah. And uh,
they had a line at the end of the
show and essentially they were saying,
shit happens and it was a big deal.
I'll bet it was a big deal that they
want it to be able to say shit happens.
And apparently they pulled this off and
they got it through and it was like a
10:00 PM show. So it was okay. And it was
11 o'clock by the time they said Shit.
And a, I remember thinking
like, wow, what a strange,
sort of like how many people were
involved in this sort of dance,
like how many lawyers and executives
and who, it's very strange,
very strange that this one word w
tr everybody knows the word, right.
It's not even that. It's kind of a,
you know, a kind of game. We all, yes.
So,
but you're saying this game is facilitated
by one specific part of the brain and
so that because like I don't swear, words
are taboo words, right? Taboo words.
And I'll often associated with
things that we find offensive, uh,
or with bodily acts that freak
people out. So, but so there's both,
there's a psychological
social aspect to it,
but there's also a
neurological aspect to it.
Now when the words like some,
some words for some people,
like I remember when I was a kid, uh, I
lived in Florida for a little bit and uh,
I said,
hell once and uh,
in Florida in the 1970s,
hell was a swear. Like, uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
I mean I came from New Jersey and then
I was in San Francisco and then all
sudden I was in Florida and I
said, hell. And they're like,
don't swear like that in this class.
I was like,
swear the fuck are you
people talking about?
Like it doesn't make any sense to me.
And that I was like,
you guys have different swears. Yeah. Now,
if you had a word that
was not taboo to you,
would it be,
would that same area of your brain?
I know, no, this is, there has
not been a lot of research.
It hasn't been taken seriously.
But that's all interesting questions.
It shouldn't have buddy.
Because some,
I mean if you're a really
super conservative person,
there's a lot of words that are off the
table. Yeah. But if you are a far more,
but you know she's loose with your
language, you could shit this and this,
God dammit. You know, that
would be nothing like Goddamn,
it would be just like Aww shucks.
Yeah, yeah. But to someone, God damn,
it would be like a really bad deal.
Really big deal.
So like what it would be different parts
of the brain would be activated by that
versus if you said it,
it would be not that big a deal,
but if someone was like super conservative
and they said, or even yeah, more. Wow.
Yeah. Interesting. What do you
think that that is a universal,
I mean it seems to be, seems to be
university seems to be universal.
Another finding that came across is
that people who learn a second language,
that swearing in the second language
does not have the same emotional impact
that your first language.
Does that make sense?
That's why they're so fun
when you learn Spanish swears,
it's like you get a free ride. Yeah.
Yeah. That's, that's interesting. Yeah.
That makes sense. Yeah. And you can
do them on television too, right?
You can say a lot of Spanish swears on
English speaking TV and everybody just
pleads ignorance. Do you,
so does every language, yes.
They all have sweaters. Every
language has words. Swear words. Wow.
That's universal. That is really
interesting. It'd be Asian languages,
European languages, all
of them, Huh. Wow. Huh.
So that, that would, at least to my brain,
seem to indicate that there's
like some use for that. Yes. Well,
probably many uses.
One is this thing of a modulating pain.
What does a social bonding, you
know, forming some community. Yeah.
That's how I kind of use it.
I think when I swear in front of people,
I'm testing them out. Yeah. Like you
freaking out. If I say, fuck you,
I can't talk to you. Right. Like,
you too much work. Right. You know?
You know what I mean?
I know exactly what you're talking to
someone in every other word like quo.
We're really wished you wouldn't
use that language. Well, okay. Yeah.
This is so much work to do
here. I can't, I know exactly.
Hold your hand dance through this
garden. Right? Yeah. It's, um,
it's to me also like,
I hang around with a lot of people that
swear a lot because I hang around with
professional comedians and fighters and
there's a lot of swashbuckling freewill
and type of individuals
involved in those pursuits.